my name is why Orion like the
constellation yeah all right okay yeah
how old are you you're three yeah well
it is this three is that three is that
three okay okay good just checking
I'm just checking so what do you listen
to before you take it back when it's
bath time you listen to Startalk
do you like it okay
what do you like about it
house you talking what do you like what
do you like the doctor Jason talks about
[Music]
okay does it make is it fun you learn
something you learn stuff so you like
this book oh yeah yeah that's me so you
like Startalk yeah that's a whole star
talk look we're the Soyuz launch from
Kazakhstan cosmic Skylab that was a long
time ago Skylab and what's this right
here that's the space okay and what's
this here and that's or space Wow
okay just checking
oh no you don't know that one okay let's
see what else we got here whoa-ho-ho mm
beep oh that's your power yeah it's
launching and there's the spacecraft hmm
and what's this right here
Lander yeah very good a man and what's
that the boot print yes yeah well you
know everything you don't need to give
and even need the book when do you have
to look for if you know everything
astronauts
that's silly
that's silly kitty cat in a suit that's
so easy yeah that's really some things
are silly he's three today and just got
this book from Grandma okay and so what
is this
that's a black hole oh yeah you want to
avoid you don't want to go near a black
hole cuz who would eat you you want to
be eaten
yeah neither do I yeah yeah so that's it
so I'm glad you like the book on the top
of the Sawyer's yeah okay and the bottom
is
sweat so do you like rockets yeah what a
rockets do okay that's true you know you
can't send the whole rocket have to
leave some stages behind yeah I fall
back into ocean well yeah they they drop
the the solid rocket boosters back into
the ocean they drop the fuel tank -
that's right yup that one else thanks
for correcting me based on contains yeah
and then this shuttle goes up to orbit
all by itself right no more no more
tanks they were solid rocket boosters
right and what's that on your shirt and
what's that sitting on top of what is
that object yeah I think that's the moon
yeah yeah I think that's the moon well
thank you for your interest you say hi
to the video say hi video okay okay say
bye